welcome to this video playing castle am
cassoulet and grand form I know it's I
am I still say yam cannot help myself I
have not not yet managed to study this
to UM to a really good good degree yeah
he seems to know it if I go nite f-4s
Bishop b5 I think wow do you cancel on
here Oh someone really knows this really
well then it gets tricky for someone
like me you is just experimenting with
the opening it doesn't really know any
details yes so Bishop g4 is what is
trying to blame
can I go like a 5 and 25 there should be
three then d five or so is that I don't
know I cannot cannot invent this now or
it's wrong what I'm trying to say what
I'm trying to say is I cannot remember
this now I just have to hope that it
works somehow OOP t8 was my adium not
sure which one
Bishop g4 I wanted to play rook g5 and
possibly night f4 rookie 5k can go
Quincy three maybe this is really a move
hmm what about Bishop g5 is this a move
Bishop g5 Quincy three install
and far too slow here and oops and for
up to seven Wow
Wow each was hanging first and i think i
have quincy for up to seven quincy for
this kind of idea okay so let's do this
for Bishop e3
like to keep that pawn if possible
and it's wait wait wait open before is
awesome okay that's probably not a bad
idea opening it up as far as possible
kiedy to create and that's it I think
check
I was very scary how quickly played
those opening loss check check check
check white resigns I had a bad feeling
about this okay well I I know that this
is this is this is some just a normal
line this and maybe night f4 immediately
I was bit scared about Bishop b5 but
that's not made maybe I thought can play
this then but I was really a bit scared
well he took no time whatsoever whether
your main problem was I was really
thinking that we should be five is this
is going to be a problem but it's not of
course I'm not made here it's not made
check came so this he went down empty
five chicks chicks so the computer at
least is not giving a loss or anything
and now it it says bishop t5 this is bad
yeah Quincy three Quincy 3m I was not
not sure what I should to act that and
it does win it does win I just felt like
I should play a move out of my lane and
g6 is also possible yeah you know what I
overlooked I was thought I thought I
could probably take this takes chat
Higgs and this
he can take and go Lucas am i over
looked at this to bishops I hanging yeah
that was that was the thing and he just
took this and is lost in two seconds why
did he do that I mean even if you don't
see Queen c3 you can still do this right
yeah this is quincy for I thought and
black is winning yeah computer agrees
Quincy for is again good but I wanted to
and to activate this end and then
clarify the situation so yeah what if we
add game you could have played Quincy
through Quincy three and this would have
been winning okay well thanks for
watching